foreign
[Music]
welcome everybody to another episode of
the careful boys we have with us on the
hot seat today Mr Bobby hundreds oh wow
wow big deal so the way that hot seat
works is you get asked a variety of
different questions that okay
increasingly hotter in temperature okay
but we like to start off with Bart
giving the coldest possible question
imaginable okay softballs yeah okay sure
this one's not really a softball but
um that you like to draw
if you could use face paint
to paint your wing or anything
in any form or whatever animal insect
what would you paint your wiener into
why are we using face paint to do this
is it because it's non-toxic why are we
calling it a wiener yeah a weenie okay
that's better thank you we
makes it sound a lot more girthier yeah
bigger and would you choose when your
wee-wee is sleeping or when it's working
out oh
I want him robust and ready for action
okay then what would you paint on I just
more surface area
um what animal would I choose anything
it could be a rocket it could be it
could be an Incredible Hulk oh wow gosh
you'd be surprised I've never thought
about this before I am surprised not a
real artist I I like hyenas because they
have a sense of humor and they're funny
but they're also like bone crushing
Predators but they don't do well on
their own which is kind of like your
your wee-wee is what you're saying so I
would like to be in the company of many
others
if you want to do something if you want
to do some damage you got to be in a
pack yeah what do you call a pack of
wee-wees you know there's like a murder
of crows or like a flock of geese like
what is it when it's a bunch of wieners
a large package no that's only one
that's only one sausage fest sausage
sausage fast yeah that's full circle so
you would paint it parmesan a hyena I
don't think it would be recognized
visible as a I don't think anyone would
be able to tell do you think your wife
would be like oh wow an armless legless
hyena
[Laughter]
surprised by I think she'd be most
shocked that I was painting my penis
pain specifically probably be the most
alarming like no this is adult face
paint yeah so that he's checking the
door the whole time oh adult face paint
you're right yeah every adult has that
in their medicine cabinet okay so the
next question we turn up a little bit oh
that wasn't okay
the next question is
um before the hundreds had the stability
or like the the the I guess position
that it has in streetwear before it made
its like solid Mark okay on your way up
what was the brand that you're like
[ __ ] got him then I gotta get
him I gotta knock them out yeah or I
gotta be like I gotta if I could only be
in their shoes oh if I could only be in
their shoes I mean yeah it was probably
a mix of both of those things when we
were starting what were we really
looking at I mean there weren't brands
that we hated or wanted to take over but
we were definitely inspired by a-life
Supreme Vape extra large fresh dive and
um I don't know why I'm thinking about
this but there was a moment uh probably
about 10 years ago when like Huff was
really coming up and they were
dominating they had they had their weed
socks and then they were doing these
Thrasher collabs and everyone in terms
of on the category level we were being
on the same rack and shelf as that brand
so a lot of people are comparing us and
we couldn't compare to how half I mean
Keith huffnagel was a rest in peace was
like you know a veteran Escape order and
had like a really great core community
of people
um but I always admired what they were
doing 10 years every year it's a
different brand and it's not necessarily
I call them I think I've talked about
this before these invisible Wars where I
I pit myself against people whether they
know it or not and it's not necessarily
that I don't like them but it's also
because for me a lot of my inspiration
motivation comes from having to be
competitive right and so sometimes it's
the Korean side of you I knew it I was
like this man has not yet been proven to
be Korean but this part invisible doors
everyone's always like oh you're picking
these fights and I'm like yeah they're
not even really personal a lot of them
are fabricated just to get me to be
incentivized to like enter the fight
right like I need to do that surfing we
were talking about surfing surfing
reminds me a lot of that too it's just
you're constantly like running into
waves you're going out and it's
nonsensical the ocean's trying to spit
you on into the sand and you keep
jumping back in it's like hey they're
telling you to like get Nature's like
please don't come in here you're like no
I want to fight I want to try I want to
go up against this thing it's a very
Korean thing but when did you get into
surfing probably about eight nine years
ago now yeah so later in my life what
made you go ah we're starting a brand
with our friends the marshals who are
they kind of like run Malibu yeah and so
um trace and Chad at the time were like
hey if we're gonna like work on this
thing together you know we really want
you you need to know how to surf and I
was like I've always wanted to Surf I
skate in a snowboard and but no one's
ever taken me and they were like show up
at Venice at 7 30 in the morning I was
there and then I never looked back wow
Venice is so hard to surf on it is so
the thing is if you can surf in Venice
you can surf anywhere oh that makes
sense dude what if you didn't like
surfing what did I what if you didn't
like surfing and then you had to pretend
like you do for the brand yeah
the socks that would happen to me I just
know it would I'd be like yeah it was
great out there I like all these bruises
that's so funny I never even entertained
that possibility thank god it worked out
we aren't involved in that brand anymore
but in the beginning we were just
helping them out it got it got too
hooked hey was there some was there like
coming up because oh God we all do this
[ __ ] right we're like you get
precious about your little thing yeah
you know and if you're what little thing
my little thing yeah you're no yeah your
penis
about your your art and your like yeah
pretentious artist [ __ ] yeah yes yes and
then and like you had to
you know lash out at things that didn't
need to be lashed out at right maybe
yeah what are we talking about I feel
like we're talking about my deep seated
me for psychology
because we all do we all do stuff I
remember coming up in the comedy world
and be like that's hack that's hacked
like did you see stuff in the in the
fashion world or and go that tax [ __ ]
can't believe they're doing that [ __ ]
and then nowadays you would do that and
you're like why was I so stupid oh yeah
100 yeah we were very early on uh when
we're starting the brand I remember we
were walking around with like this real
street where OG I'm not gonna call him
out by name and we were walking by the
LRG booth at the trade show and in those
early days this is like very early 2000s
LRG was King right they were bigger than
Supreme they were like the biggest ones
and Kanye was wearing them and you know
they had all the rappers in their
lookbooks and their catalogs and whatnot
and we were walking by in the street
where OG was just like I never want to
be there and I was like yeah [ __ ] that I
never want to be their sellouts and they
sell to department stores and you know
they've got millions of dollars all
their employees have benefits they were
like Jonas and Robert were like driving
around Lamborghinis Ben Baller right
that was like the beginning of all of
that and we were like we never want to
be that and then you know you get to a
certain point where like oh I have
overhead I need to support employees I
have a family now I you know I want to
like be able to oh why are you so greedy
yeah
it's like kind of need to make money
because it's not selling out it's buying
in right exactly it's buying it yeah no
that's great no because uh yeah
something that I've noticed about
especially the fashion world like you
were you mentioned earlier it changes so
rapidly yeah you talked about
Reinventing yourself every day is that
really a thing or is that just something
that people say like how do you actually
no I really do feel like I'm having to
reinvent myself constantly just because
the nature of everything is moving so
fast and especially because we're
involved in the nft and crypto and Tech
side that moves even faster where rules
that were set up like goal posts that
were set up today they move like
literally hourly where it's like oh this
is what you're supposed to do now
everyone's like no that's what you don't
do anymore then how do you ever find who
you really are I think that's part of
the skill you have to have a strong
stomach for some of these businesses
right because the appeal is that every
day you know my wife always says like
every day you come home it's like your
job is so Dynamic it's like you you know
it's so exciting but also just so risky
right you always have a different story
to tell I'm like it is you know like
when I'm but I have I have crazy ADHD
and I cannot focus so it makes sense for
me I can't I couldn't stick to the same
task for 30 years I just it's just not
in me to do that but you never was like
oh if only I had like a a Peanut Farm
why am I talking like that all of a
sudden because you're troubled
oh if only I had a peanut Farm it would
be life would be so much
it's like every day you gotta change and
it's like I would love that yeah but
what about cashew Farm that's what I'm
saying is that some people think that
they want this kind of life and they're
like oh your life is so exciting and
every day you're doing these different
things I'm like it is exhausting yeah
right the addiction of having novel
things constantly is such a [ __ ] pain
in the ass it is because I'm like why
can't I just be stimulated with eating
oatmeal every [ __ ] day it should be
enough
it's just it's greed it really is greed
and we is it green or is it stimulation
Joe's trouble now it's like the problem
is a disease of abundance right this is
not a scarcity economy or a scarcity
Society anymore where for Generations
like our parents grandparents that's
what they always knew so we had to save
because we never knew when things were
going to run out and you never had
enough and so you really appreciated
things you had one of things if you
could even afford that but now we have
like a real abundance problem not just
with like material possessions but
content entertainment right there's like
anything you want you can order food and
a whim like my kids use Postmates
sometimes and they don't even know what
they're buying because everyone has just
so much money like if you have means
like if you have wealth right now you
have way too much right more than you'll
ever need and if you have clothes right
now you have more clothes than you'll
ever need which is something that I have
to deal with daily is like I'm
constantly supplying clothing or I'm
like we have enough clothing on this
planet to last for two and a half
Generations we don't need more product
you don't you don't need that fast you
probably I needed it when you posted it
on your Instagram I convinced you
because all of that you needed it is
because like damn dude but I think
that's like the real like we have a real
disease of abundance it's not just like
too much food or it's not just too much
it's like too much of everything just
too many movies too many choices too
many choices so like now we don't choose
too much news it's too many pundits too
many opinions and it's like well who are
we I don't know you know it's just it's
good so what excites you these days what
excites you how do you get up out of bed
I mean look this is a dark world you
just described I just it is it is dark I
think it's dark but I don't I actually
think the world is better now in many
ways than it was many years ago there's
a really really great book called
fatfulness by Hans roslinger who died in
the process of writing he was like very
old but even does it just stop at one
point it literally does it doesn't
really that's because family comes in
and finishes the book and they're like
look he because he knew he was dying in
the Miss event he's like this is my
parting message with the world that
you're actually much better off than you
realize you know the media and the
social media is like telling you a
certain way but I mean just think about
like well we've been able to cure in
terms of like infant mortality rates
right and like Global medication we've
been able to save there's so much less
disease now and people aren't having to
have like 10 and kids in like third
world countries in order for one to
survive like they can have one or two
children they can get them education now
in medicine like and we got rid of
abortion the progress
yeah and so like I didn't hear what that
was maybe it's better I didn't hear yeah
it was way better yeah continue just
agree with it
he was with it I pretended like I didn't
hear it okay so but yeah I think anyways
we can go down I'm I think I'm actually
really
inspired by most people like I just
think this is like a really great time
to be alive like people are pursuing
things that they were told for
Generations they can't do and now you're
seeing them having these breakthrough
moments where they can try anything they
want and make like somewhat of a living
a lot of people are like surviving doing
that that's great I think that's really
really great news like Asian being Asian
Americans seeing representation like did
you ever think that it would be cool to
be Asian and now it's cool on many
levels in terms of like pop music and
film and TV and everyone's watching
squid game that sounds really boring I'm
asking another question okay okay sorry
yeah it wasn't bad enough so that's your
opinion that's not everyone's opinion
yeah you're it's it is my opinion dude
I'm gonna punch this guy in in all the
years you've done business what was the
the single hardest thing that has ever
happened to you nfcs oh for real why
because you lost a lot of money it was
the heart and it continues to be the
hardest instrument uh you did your own
project You Lose Yourself
um
I understand about nfts is if you're
setting it up the honest way right as
honest as it can get you're actually
building a project that uh you're trying
to involve the community right and you
don't build the rug into it right yeah
well you have to start at that rug yeah
you're essentially like raising money
for a company and then you raise the
money and you leave the company which is
when a lot of people are building nfts
that's how they think of it they're like
oh I'm creating a project of these
Collectibles or I'm selling art and then
I meant it people buy it and then I'm
done but that's you're departing from
the company that you're exiting which is
not fair because those people are like
oh I bought it and I want you to do
something with this yeah yeah yeah I
didn't know that most people didn't know
that this time of year ago they were
looking at nfts almost like Collectibles
like that's just it and then board Apes
came around and people were like oh you
can actually build a utility and meaning
into these Collectibles and so to put
out a project we did 25 000 nfts they
sold out in 40 minutes the real work
began and then we worked on those for
like eight months I thought my job was
done and then the work really began the
next day when people were like okay now
what are you doing yeah where's the
roadmap right and it's a different
relationship than a brand to Consumer
consumers are essentially fans where
they're just like really happy just to
be a partner they're like shareholders
these people are shareholders and
partners and they feel like they're
owners not everyone but it's there's
like this conflation because I was
coming into thinking of Morris
Collectibles and we're here for the art
and that's like the approach we're
bringing in it with but a lot of these
people are Traders day Traders flippers
who are like no no we're investors and
that's the murky gray territory of nfts
that makes it Dynamic and fun but it
also confuses a lot of people because
you see a lot of projects fall apart
because they're not equipped to be able
to provide anything thankfully we were
right because we're an actual company
that we're like no we're going to be
doing a lot of things for you forever
but it's hard because we've never had to
share the company before the brand or
the decisions that's what web theory is
about it's decentralize realizing it's
not just you supporting a company
anymore it's like you actually have say
in like a vote democracy sucks what
happens right and so right like this
gets into like political issues as well
it's like do you want democracies or
liberal illiberal democracies where
you're getting letting do you really
want everyone to vote right so it's like
do you want that because now you're
getting into territory where you're
getting certain people involved in the
government that you probably don't want
so but isn't this more akin to like you
know you you have people who have who
have a stake in it right they actually
bought into it so it's almost like
shareholders voting yeah so then if you
look at the positive way which we do is
that these people are actually there to
help you right they're not there to
decry or to say that you guys are
rugging and they're actually like no
we're here to help and so instead of
looking at it like it's baggage you can
look at it like now you have thousands
of Partners who are like I'll do
anything to help spread the word so your
brand now moves like exponentially
faster which it does now right and so
there's two ways of looking at it most
if you look at the negative way you're
saddled with like complainers and you're
doing customer service and trying to
appease people or you can look at the
way that we do which is oh these people
are comrades right like they're here to
all see us win this you know and we can
move so much faster in different
territories we never had access to
before so they're all doing marketing
they're all selling and they're all
preaching it there's like me and now
there's thousands of other me's who are
in their neighborhoods and communities
telling people about like the hundreds
you don't have to work so hard and I
shouldn't have to work so hard I can
attack a lot of niches that way right so
like there's a lot of community
involvement in these niches where they
have governance votes and now they
actually have a reason to support your
burgeoning ecosystem it's not just some
[ __ ] thing like we all go vote and
then we all get disappointed right yeah
right yeah this actually your vote can
actually matter in the long run you can
directly influence the the future of the
project what do you think about the nft
market right now though like like you
know I don't know what you would argue
how much of them is a scam like would
you say I'd say a lot of them are scam
but it and it also goes into like what
is a scam am right and I don't mean to
get super existential and deep and
philosophical about it but like what is
a scam I was just talking about vebellum
Goods like all luxury goods are in a way
a scam like you don't need a Chanel
purse like a regular purse is fine like
that's but she's not happy for like at
least three months so you have to get it
so that's true because is it a scam what
is a scam like how do you define that if
someone is just hopeful they have no
experience and then they they manage to
convince everybody like yo give me this
money I have this great idea I don't
have any experience but believe in me
and then they get the money and they
fail is that a scam or you just invested
into someone that I think Case by case I
think that's a person by person because
I see the nft crypto space kind of like
that right you got you have a bunch of
guys that you know they're like yo I'm
really trying to make this happen yeah
not all of them work out some of them
are outright scans where they're like
hey let's do this hustle there are a lot
of those were they predetermined right
but then not all failures are scams
either right so it's it's a it's a real
gray area and I think when all when
there's something new anytime there's an
emerging like industry or whatever it
just happens this way or even even in
business right like they say 90 of
business fail within five years yeah so
were those scams none of them are meant
to be scams they're trying to make it
and in the next five it's 50 well isn't
the underlying Tech event I mean it
wasn't this for me anyway for nfts just
talks her up a little bit of energy like
the what we just went was almost like
the 90s tech stocks bubble like the
pest.com and all that kind of [ __ ] yeah
so like a lot of failure but maybe
well-intentioned failure right but then
the underlying Tech like the stuff
behind entities it's very real very real
right yeah so that part of it the
blockchain technology is very real and
then for most people who know anything
about tech and that's why there's so
much investment going into blockchain
technology we all are gonna have to
we're gonna be paying receipts and
they'll be on the blockchain and you
know there will be instead of there's
companies right now that I know they're
like you pull up to a parking meter and
you can pay it through your car instead
of having to get out and doing the thing
and that's all recorded on blockchain so
we're gonna need all that type of tech
the way that it's being marketed and
packaged right now as like the pets.com
sort of the whatever it looks silly but
that's the part of any burgeoning
industry is like you're going to have
these capitalists and opportunities
coming in trying to make money doing it
and then they're gonna fail and then
you're gonna be like well what did we
actually build with the tech in the
meantime what's your take on the
metaverse
I think most of what the narrative like
the mediated metaverse like what you
hear about is complete [ __ ] like
that part of metaverse is just a
repackaging a rebranding a VR AR and
video games right and uh it's all
fragmented too it's there's no one
metaverse right and so like a real true
metaverse which we'll see if it ever
happens if anything it'll take five to
six to ten years is an interoperable
metaverse so the skin you buy in
fortnite you can use in valorant and
then you can bring it into Facebook and
like it should work like that and but
you're a lawyer imagine that I know
that's the nightmares getting Activision
and Riot and all the game companies to
work together so why would they this is
insane why would they do a masculine
question about the meta verse then let's
say you're in the metaverse and your
wife pisses you off in the metaverse can
you soccer on the metaverse I would uh
soccer avatars yeah I don't I would not
I would probably not do that why you'd
hire someone else what you would even
beat up your wife in Mortal Kombat I
cannot beat up my wife this is thing my
wife is so much stronger than I am like
she's like a very she works out
constantly in real life but in the meta
version I think even in the metaverse
she would really put me in this stats
would just be way too high yes yes yeah
she's very strong sounds like a button
Master to me so for um you and and Ben
have been Partners how many years now 19
years so uh yeah that as impressive as
that is that you guys have never had a
falling out period oh no no no there's
always falling out of course there's
always arguments and fights so I I don't
trust people who are in relationships
and they're like oh we never fight I'm
like oh you're gonna break up and it's
gonna be disaster how do you know
someone without fighting have you ever
had like a close friend you have to
fight to get to know someone yeah like
you need to see that side of him since
all depths and nuances of who people are
it's like the nasty dark insecure Parts
this scared parts of fearful parts and
then like The Confident versions of
themselves like you need to know all
that [ __ ] has that ever happened where
one of you were like I'm out of here yes
multiple times oh [ __ ] it's always me
yeah I'm like because I'm like uh I was
always like a Runway as a kid I ran away
so many times like because that's just
my nature anytime there's something
difficult happens I want to run yeah and
I'm just like [ __ ] this I'm out I like
doing the really ceremonious like I'm
out of here so it's like I'm gonna show
you but it always like backfires on me
it's like the Jerry Maguire like I'm out
of here and then everyone just returns
back to work like no one really misses
you or care so the office does really
well everyone does better actually
without me they all get raises I know
that but um yeah there have been many
moments where I've just been like I
didn't know how to deal with this and
I'm out and it's just you know like 40
minutes later I'm like I'm sorry you
know like I don't really mean that's
crazy because I can't be me without Ben
and Ben can't do what he does without me
we are very much aware of that but of
course we're like we're brothers we're
family we're just you never felt one day
[ __ ] this I could do this all my own I
think every entrepreneur thinks that
like always right and I think
um you know that's just like a very
natural feeling of like I don't need
anyone I can do on my own I know I can
do it on my own do I want to do it on my
own oh no will I be able to do it as
well on my own definitely not like there
are things that Ben does that I never
know how I will never know how to do I
don't have the talents and I don't want
to do it you don't ever like want to
just slightly like cheat on Ben though
like you see like another guy and
they're like damn this guy's better at
Ben than Ben is I want to start I've
never met anyone who's better at being
Ben than I really have never what does
what's been good at I think well first
of all he's number one he's good at
dealing with me because I'm like a very
messy person so he's like the most
patient with me right and then I think I
can say the same for him everyone I
write about this in the book where his
friends at first were just like ah how
do you deal with him every day I'm like
I don't know I usually have a pretty
short patience for a lot of friends I'm
like not the chillest person but for him
like I just I love him you know we just
have so much respect for each other so
that's something I talk about a lot too
with like relationships is it's like do
you have it comes down to respect and
like I never lose respect for the guy I
trust him and I believe in him and so
like it'll be fine regardless of what we
go through you know but I've never met
anyone else who I've been like
you know I've ever seen that in no no
never wanted to cheat but that's a
really interesting I've seen Ben hang
out with like the Supreme guys a lot
lately
yeah oh you Hood popping bro yeah Ben's
always had like in and out with them and
I'm like what are you guys doing over
here he goes oh don't tell Bobby you saw
me here so she says what do you tell
your kids about because we were talking
about the dark future all that stuff
yeah how do you prepare them for a
potential dark future I think I'm we're
very honest in our house uh talking
about all this stuff we talk to them
just like they're regular folks our age
and I I think some people they think
it's a little too extreme they're like
oh do you have to talk I'm like yeah I
just you know how old are they they're
now they're 13 and 10 but we've been
ever since they're kids old enough
anything that was on the news was fair
play right and like controversial or
embattled topics like transgenderism for
example or just like presidential races
like these are all things that we openly
discuss because I'm I'm never clear or
adamant about I have the answers or the
truth I think all that stuff is
malleable and like not fixed right so
it's just like let's talk about it let's
figure out I don't know Dad why is it
like this or why did they say that or
how can it be this way and I'm like I
don't know either let's try to you you
might teach me more than I might teach
you on that subject I don't know so
we're very transparent about it and I
also need I try as much to balance like
when there's a lot of dark stuff in the
news school shootings right like also
just talking about well what was war
like in past Generations right and this
is we don't have as many of those types
of Wars this is a different kind of War
we're embroiled in but the wars my
parents grew up in during the Korean War
like you know previous situations with
like Japan Japanese imperialism and like
rape and torture like we don't have that
and thank God we don't have that you
know but this is a different kind of
Ward A different kind of context now
that we're trying to navigate and I'm
like you're going to war every single
day just like my parents did just like
their Generations before did it's a
different kind of War some of it's
psychological and digital Warfare like
you know people hacking in yesterday I
think this week LAUSD uh my kid's school
uh District got hacked by Russia or
something I didn't know who hacked it
but everything was offline for the day
they had to reset their passwords it's
huge disruption whoa right and I'm like
that's Warfare right I don't know if
it's coming internationally or if it's
domestic but it's some type of terrorism
that you guys went off the grid and now
we lost a day of Education like that
affects us As Americans it affects us as
Citizens so that's something my
grandparents never had to deal with yeah
you know but like that [ __ ] sucks
that you had to do that so we talk about
we try to be as relevant as objective as
possible when we're talking about like
oh every day like people are dying of
guns in this country and it's like it's
a horrible tragedy and like we got to
figure out ways to amend that but it's
also like let's be real it's not like
the world is ending you know like it's
not like it's not dismal like we can fix
these things we we're here to fix the
things that's you know and we refuse it
with hope what's that you infuse it with
hope I tried just like practical realism
you know I think that it's important to
just be real I'm not trying to be
sugarcoat anything I'm like yeah that's
like terrible that that happened and we
watch the news together we'll watch
certain clips of you know families
morning lost ones and I'm like God thank
God that that didn't happen to our
family you know thank God we don't have
that here and like let's be grateful
that we have this every single day you
know so like we're very realistic about
things but just let's understand what
else is happening outside of this media
Spotlight or what everyone's talking
about there's also things happening in
the shadows right and so just trying to
make them as aware as possible of
everything going on instead of just what
these people are talking about all the
time I think that's important damn
that's a lot of work being a paradigm
I'm afraid to be a father I'm just
already figuring out my Escape Plan
it's great kids are amazing I think
people these days they treat the kids
like they're really fragile no I can't
wait to abuse them only like kids this
was like the first generation the last
couple generations to treat children
this way before like in the early 1900s
kids worked on the farms you yeah you
bred Kids To Work hell yeah and so it's
like as soon as you can stand up like
get to work and you're tough and you're
resilient and like death is a part of
life and like we're gonna all go through
this together and now it's just like
it's like we treat them like they're
these like flowers and that's they're
not they're amazing like and they're so
bright I'm sure I I remember being a
young person always being like why do
why are your parents talking to me like
this I understand what they're saying
they're really brilliant creatures and
so it's like they're actually fine on
their own like my grandfather my
great-grandfather immigrated from Korea
to Japan by foot Barefoot six years old
eating out of the garbage cans like
eating trash it was a very common story
there's a book in a film called Pachinko
that kind of tells a lot of this this
migration from like area to Japan but
it's like they were fine you know and
like they figured it out like kids are
fine you know one of the food back then
was all organic they didn't have gluten
better trash quality what I hate about
me is that I just logged that away in my
brain to call your grandpa a trash eater
later
[Laughter]
yeah but your dad eats trash
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]